محمود شكرا سلمى مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا
الكرام في هذه النافذه للتحليل العسكري
لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه وفيها
نستضيف المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز
الدويري لكن نتابع اخر تطورات المشهد
ميدانيا على الخريطه التفاعليه مع عبد
القادر عرض عبد القادر نعم محمود ولعلي
سانطرح من الشمال بالنظر الى تطوراته
اللافته في الساعات الاخيره وحينما نتحدث
عن الشمال ربما سنركز على هذه التطورات
اللافته على هذا المحور الذي طالما تحدثنا
عنه وهو محور التفاح والدرج حيث اعلنت
كتائب القسام عن استهدافها لخمس اليات
عسكريه على مستوى هذا المحور هناك
اشتباكات عنيفه على مستوى محور التفاح
والدرج لكن اللافت ايضا هو ما اعلنته
القسام عن تمكنها من استهداف فوهه النفق
وايضا عددا من الجنود في هذه الفوهه وقالت
بانها اردت عددا من الجنود الاسرائيليين
على مستوى جبل الريس بين قتيل وجريح حينما
نشير الى هذا المحور فاننا نشير ايضا الى
الاخبار التي تحدثت عن تحرك للقوات
الاسرائيليه من التفاح والدرج نتيجه ضغط
المقاومه على مستوى هذا المحور باتجاه جبل
الريس اذا محور ملتهب ولعله يعيد ايضا الى
الاذهان ويرتبط ايضا بالتطورات اللافته
التي حدثت على محور اخر وهو محور الشيخ
رضوان وايضا حي النصر حيث لوحظ ايضا تحرك
للقوات الاسرائيليه خارج الشيخ رضوان هذه
التطورات ايضا في الشمال تاتي بينما ايضا
تعرض مخيم جباليا وجباليا لعملي قصف
اسرائيلي استهدف استهدف جباليا ولكن ايضا
كان لافت ما حدث في الجبهه الشماليه نحن
نشير بالاساس الى بيت لاهيه و بيت حنون
حيث تمكنت المقاومه تحديدا كتائب القسام
واعلنت عن تمكنها من الاستحواذ على
طائرتين
طائره طائره مسيره في بيت حانون وكان ايضا
هناك ايضا تمكنها ايضا الاستحواذ على
طائره في بيت لاهيه تطورات في الشمال لا
تغيب عنها تطورات المنطقه الوسطى وتحديدا
ربما نركز على هذه التطورات هنا في البريج
من خلال ايضا اعلان كتائب القسام عن
استهدافها ل في كمين لقوه راجله في البريج
البريج التي تشهد ايضا محاولات اسرائيليه
للتوغل والتقدم لكن المقاومه سواء كتائب
القسام او سرايا القدس تعلن عن استهدافها
لعدد من الدبابات على مستوى هذا المحور في
وقت ايضا يتم هناك قصف للصراط والزوايده
في هذا المحور ربما نختم بالمحور الجنوبي
وتحديدا خان يونس وتطورات معلنه لكتائب
القسام عن استهداف ايضا قوه راجله هنا في
منطقه الجراره وهي احد محاور التوغل
الاسرائيلي منذ
بدايه منذ بدايه العمليات على مستوى خان
يونس ولكن ايضا تمكنها ايضا من استهداف
عدد من الاليات العسكريه على مستوى هذا
المحور خصوصا محور الجراره اذا كمائن في
الجنوب وايضا تطورات في الوسط ولكن ايضا
في الشمال على مستوى محاور التفاح نعم عبد
القادر سنناقش هذا مع اللواء فايز الدويري
سياده اللواء يعني هذه الاشتباكات وهذه
العمليات المحتدم تقريبا في كل قطاع غزه
في الشمال في محور الدرج وال التفاح وفي
الوسط في كما كما قال عبد القادر وهناك في
الجنوب الجراره في خان يونس ماذا تقرا في
هذا التطور يعني دعنا نقسم قطاع غزه الى
ثلاثه اجزاء القاطع الشمالي وهو الذي يقع
ال الشمال من وادي غزه وهي مدينه غزه وما
حولها وذكر بعض المناطق التفاح
والدرج والشيخ
رضوان منذ اكثر من عره ايام بدات قوات جيش
الاحتلال تخفف من تواجدها في منطقه الشيخ
رضوان ولكن بعد ان تخلت او انسحبت او
اجبرت على التراجع من المنطقه الشرقيه
تمسكت في المنطقه الغربيه ومن ثم حاولت ان
تطور عملياتها ولكن هذا هذا التحول الجديد
لم يفلح فتحت معركه الدرج
والتفاح رغم ذلك لم تحقق انجازات هذا هذا
الاطار من العمليات العسكريه تزامن مع
الاعلان عن اعاده التموضع اذا جاز التعبير
من حيث اولا سحب خمسه الويه وهي الالويه
لم تك في لحظه الاعلان مشتبك كانت قد تم
نقلها مسبقا اذا هناك يبدو توجه لدى جيش
الاحتلال ان ينكف الى المناطق الزراعيه
الان عندما يريد ان يتخلص من معركه يكثف
من الاستهداف الناري حتى يمنع القوات
المقابله ويجبرها على قطع التماس لانه هو
عندما يريد ان يتخل ينسح من منطقه النقطه
الاولى التي يسعى لتحق
قطع التماس قطع التماس
يعني منع القوات المقابله من ادامه
الالتحام المباشر معه في ظل الحرب غير
المتناظره وفي المناطق المبنيه
بالمقابل كتائب المقاومه الفلسطيني القسام
وبقيتها تستغل هذا الوضع لانه عمليه
الانفكاك من معركه تحت ضغط القتال يكون
العدو غير متزن وغير قادر على اداره
المعركه بصوره جيده فهي تحاول ان ت تزيد
من وتيره ايقاع العمليات لهذا السبب تحدث
عن الخسائر اذا ذهبنا للمنطقه الوسطى
المنطقه الوسطى الوضع
مختلف منذ البدء الهجوم في هذه المنطقه تم
تخصيص الفرقه 36 المدرعه حاولت في اليوم
الاول ان تتحرك على شارع صلاح الدين لتحقق
اختراق ما بين النصيرات والبريج ولكنها
اخفق هذه الخارطه في هذه المنطقه ولكنها
اخفقت ماذا جرى قبل ان هذا التاشير انكف
الى الخلف اعادت موضعها اعادت تطوير الخطه
وبدا تهاجم من الشمال ومن الشرق في صباح
هذا اليوم اندفعت قوات جديده كما يؤشر في
الخط الازرق الاول لو سمحت الان هذا السهم
الذي يشير الى الدخول مع شارع صلاح الدين
والانعطاف نحو الشرق الان ليضع اي مخيم
البريج بين نا اتجاه من ثلاثه مناطق من
الشمال من الشرق من الغرب لانه يسعى من
خلال هذا العمل الى اضعاف الواجهه
الشماليه والشرقيه لانها اوقعت خسائر
كبيره لا بل اكثر من ذلك دفع جزء من قوات
الفرقه 36 للحركه مع المناطق الزراعيه الى
اقصى نقطه الشمال الغربي من مخيم نصيرات
ويحاول ان يتقدم بموازاه شارع الرشيد
ليتعدى الصيرات ويتعدى الزوايده ويحاول ان
يدخل مع الاراضي القليله من حيث البناء
العمراني من وياخذ جنوب المغازي لفصل
منطقه نصيرات الزوايده
البريج والمغازي عن دير البلح في المنطقه
الجنوبيه لا يزال العمل المنطقه
الجنوبيه نذهب للمنطقه الجنوبيه عبد الان
في هذه المنطقه لا تغير
في قواعد الاشتباك وطبيعه المعارك التي
تجري في بني سيلا في الزنه في عبسان في
خزاعه استطاع ان يحقق اجتياز لشارع صلاح
الدين في بعض المناطق بقوات محدوده الحجم
ووصل الى شارع يطلق عليه شارع السكه لكن
الجديد في الامر في في هذا اليوم بروز على
اسم القراره
مجددا والان التساؤل هل القراره في خان
يونس ستك كفئ وتوازي ما ينجز في جحر الديك
في في القاطع الشمالي في غزه اتوقع ذلك
لانه هذه الارض تخدم عمليات المقاومه كما
هي جحر الديك تخدم عمليات المقاومه وبدا
العمل بها في هذا اليوم مباشره بعمليات
النوعيه وهذا ما جرى في جحر الديك انه بعد
مرور اكثر من اسبوعين ثلاث بدات الانطلاقه
جحر الديك وترسخ اسم جحر الديك في معظم
التحليلات اليوميه واتوقع القراره ان
ستعيد قصه جحر الديك ايضا ما دلالات
الحديث الذي جاءت به صحيفه هرتس
الاسرائيليه نقلا عن مسؤولين عسكريين
يتحدثون عن ان امد هذه المعركه سيطول الى
سته اشهر او المرحله من الحرب في الحقيقه
سيطول الى سته اشهر يعني الان الحديث عن
المرحله الثالثه المرحله الثاني وصفت
بايجاز من قبل قاده جيش الاحتلال بانها
ستكون اكثف و اوسع نطاقا ومتزامن استخدم
الكثافه وال والقدره الناريه والتزامن اي
تزامن العمليات العسكريه في اكثر من منطقه
المرحله الثالثه تتحدث عن مرحله انشاء او
التحكم في المناطق العازله والمناطق
العازله من وجهه نظر جيش الاحتلال تاخذ
كافه المناطق الزراعيه على على الجهه
الشماليه الجهه الشرقيه وحتى ممر
فيلادلفيا وياخذ كذلك هك خط معين بعرض لا
يقل عن كيلومتر في وادي غزه الان الوضع
بصوره
عامه بدا التحضير له منذ اكثر من عده ايام
بحيث بدا في بناء او انشاء لا اقول بناء
انشاء سواتر ترابيه بارتفاعات لا تقل عن
180 سم الى مترين لتؤمن حركه الاليات خاصه
جميع الاليات بالتحديد المدو بانها اكثر
وهنا وحركه الافراد من النيران المسدده من
قبل القوات وهذا يعني النزول من شجره
الحرب الواسعه الى العمليات الجراحيه
النوعيه تستهدف فقط القاده وبعض النقاط
سياده اللواء الفيديوهات والتسجيلات
المصوره تتتابع من فصائل المقاومه بثت
سرايا القدس صورا جديده لما قالت انها
مشاهد من عمليه وصفتها بالنوعيه استهدفت
خلالها موقع قياده وسيطره اسرائيليا جنوب
محور الزيتون لو تعلق على هذه الصور س هذه
صواريخ كتوش 70 ملم وتم اجراء تعديل عليها
بحيث لاحظ هي عمليه النصب العمليه
البدائيه يعني ليس على قواعد اطلاق وليس
بموجهات انما يتم حفر احداث ثقب صغير يتم
وضع مقدمه الصاروخ في هذا الثقب ومن ثم
يتم اغلاق الداره الكهربائيه لانه يعمل
على البطاريه اسلاك الكهرباء
وا في قد لانه لابد من اعادته بالبطيء حتى
نتاكد لانه انا شاهدت بعض الاسلاك وقد ان
يكون بعضه عمليه التفعيل الداخلي كما هو
في في قذيفه الشواط ف كلا الامرين وهذه
صواريخ كتيوشا طورت وعدلت لتستخدم بهذه
الطريقه وهذا امر متوقع وبالتالي نلاحظ
الان عمليات الاطلاق لانه الصواريخ اصلا
مقدمه الصاروخ هي ترتكز على الجذار لكن
ليس هناك اليه للتوجيه سوى ما يفعلونه
بهذه التوجيه هنا تصبح الهدف هدف منطقه
وليس هدف نقطه لانه لا يستطيع يعني لا
يوجد هناك لاشعه تحت الحمراء ولا ليزر ولا
ما شابه ذلك كتائب القسام سياده اللواء
بثت صورا قالت انها الاستهداف حشود الجيش
الاسرائيلي بقذائف الهون غرب بيت لهيه
شمالي قطاع غزه هذه الصور التي بثتها القص
سام يعني الحديث عن بيت لاهيه مجددا بعد
اقترابنا من الشهر الثثالث تمام الشهر
الثثالث لاهيه وصل اطراف بيت لاهيه في
اليوم الثاني من العمليه البريه من
المرحله الاولى نحن نتحدث عن تقريبا اي
اكثر من شهرين يعني بحدود 62 يوم وصلت
اطلاع القوات ولا تزال لاحظ الان استهدف
ال الهاون الصغير ذ المقياس الصغير اعتقد
احد المبررات
خفته يعني خفه الوزن وسهوله الحمل بحيث
لانه هذا ت يعني تحرك من نقطه ما لا
يستطيع ان ياخذه 12 ملم ثقيل يحتاج
الى وقت اكثر لتوضيح والاطلاق وبالتالي
استخدم الهاون صغير القياس يمكن يطلق عليه
لاجل سهوله الحركه طبعا والانسحاب السري
وزنه وسهوله الحركه القسام قصفت تل ابيب
بصواريخ ام 90 وهذا الفيديو عرضته القسام
امس لهذا الصاروخ ام 90 رمز للمقدمه
والمدى الاقصى 90 كيلومترا والراس الحربي
وزنه 50 كيلو جرام بعد كل هذا الوقت يعني
كما يقال كان في الدقيقه الاولى من
البدايه العام الجديد وكانها رساله من
القسام ان هذا العام سيكون له رمزيته وقد
اذا ما استمر العدوان قد ينسي هذا العام
الامكم من العام الماضي هكذا اقرا الرساله
لانه بدا بدات الدقيقه الاولى من العام
باطلاق الصواريخ وكانت ردا على تصليحات
سمعتها قبل ان تطلق الصواريخ بحوالي ساعه
بان القدره الصاروخيه تدنت كثيرا فكان
الرد في عمق بهذه السرعه شكرا جزيلا لك
سياده اللواء والمحلل العسكري فايز
الدويري شكرا لك ختام هذه النافذه
العسكريه الخاصه بحرب اسرائيل على غزه
نعود الى غرفه الاخبار مجددا